New Mutants are dangerous.
That's why you're here.
Oh scary
This isn't a hospital.
It's a cage.
Together, we can get out of here.
That thing will kill you! He's right, it's magic!
So am I
That was so hot.
All of you are dangerous.
That's why you're here.
This isn't a Hospital.
It's a cage.
We are the cast
from the New Mutants, which is unlike other
superhero movies you have a whole bunch
of really traumatized teens we're all so
different but we also have something
like massive in common not just the fact
that we have powers but that we've been
through this life experience together
and you have these things inside of you
if you struggle to deal with them.
What does that look like.
I don't think we're here to get better.
They have such an incredible relationship and
they really bring each other through
very difficult times.
We connect over who
we really are. Not in spite of who we
really are and it shows in how we all
come together and use a little bit of
our powers all together
we can get out of this
Together
What's the last thing you
remember Dani.
He said we had to run
Would anyone like to shared their first
time?
Rhaine? I was 13 I thought it was a dream.
I just lost control.
Sam?
I started panicking. People got hurt.
Roberto?
My girlfriend partner.
Illyana?
I killed 18 men.
One by one.
This isn't a hospital.
It's a cage
It's important we find out your power.
So we can help you get better.
I saw something.
I don't think she wanted me to see
I don't think we're here to get better.
We can get out of this.
Together.
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is going to be my brand new Marvel New
Mutants trailer video there's a bunch of
new footage the director even confirm
one of my big theories about their
original post-credit scenes so we'll
break it all down including what's going
on with x-men and mutants within the MCU
Kevin Feige has said some things and
they're even setting some stuff up in
the Disney Plus series that are
happening later this year if you're new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to
get all the videos there's going to be a
bunch of big stuff coming up I know
there's lots of questions too so we'll
just start with the footage then I'll
talk about the post-credits scene and
then x-men inside the MCU so we'll just
start with the footage then I'll talk
about mutants inside the MCU and the
stuff that they're setting up on the
Disney Plus series most of this new
footage focuses on their specific powers
giving you a much better look at what
they actually are on screen I think they
just had unfinished special effects
before the director said that before the
Fox Disney buyout the film was about 75%
done the rest of this mostly shows them
bonding coming together as the new
mutants x-men team while they still
think that they're inside a hospital
obviously like part of this is probably
real part of it is probably happening
inside their minds just based on what
the director has said the director
called it sort of a mix of One Flew Over
the Cuckoo's Nest with the matrix in
Nightmare on Elm Street so you're never
quite sure if what's happening is
actually really happening or if it's
just something happening inside your
mind there's a bunch more footage of
Roberto de Costa who's sunspot in the
comics showing you his personality how
he's a little bit of a poser how his
powers work they're all meant to be
teenagers which is why they have some of
those funny awkward teenager high school
style moments like when magic starts
using her powers and gets real badass he
just says that's so hot he's from a
super rich family in the comics which is
why he's the one that's dressed like
he's super preppy even though they're
making it seem like they're all trapped
inside an insane asylum because their
families think they're possessed or
crazy or just plain freaks that need to
be cured his sunspot powers look like
this in the comics so it's a little bit
different tune for the movie we get a
much better look at Charlie Heaton's
cannonball powers in action it's weird
that he's tied up to this cement block
while he's showing up his power mostly
manifests as him flying through the air
with his body hardening like a
cannonball the faster he travels so
while he's spinning around in the
he gets stronger and stronger we haven't
seen a full transformation from Maisie
Williams wolfsbane character yet but
they're probably still finishing special
effects on that make all the direwolf
Game of Thrones jokes she want Dani
moon stars powers are mostly the ability
to manifest people's deepest fears very
psychic based abilities you kind of see
that play through the footage where
she's slowly remembering these disasters
in the past like do you remember when
your powers manifested there was a
disaster they told me to run she's
probably talking about her parents
when demon bear first came to try and
kill them you see way more demon bear
during this trailer footage as the name
implies he's a giant demonic bear but he
mostly attacks people as a psychic
projection that can manifest physically
sometimes this way the movie version of
demon bear in the trailer makes him seen
kind of like the smoke monster from lost
like these big smokey effects is he real
is he fake where is he coming from part
of this reality is probably fake and a
result of him manipulating the other
kids powers without them realizing it
except for magic she seems like she's
one of the few characters that figures
out pretty early on that things aren't
what they seem it tries to slap some
sense into the other characters talking
about magic probably one of the coolest
characters in this movie she's got a
bunch of different comic book powers
she's got the soul-sword
that she manifests here it's called the
soul sword because she's projecting her
own life energy into the form of a blade
if you're a big Avatar The Last
Airbender fan it's kind of like her
energy bending the life energy within
her body like an energy bends at the end
of that series the armor that she forms
around herself is actually called the
eldritch armor it's connected to her use
of magic and sorcery the more magic she
uses the thicker and crazier the armor
gets if she continues using her magic
for long periods of time or in birla
extreme ways horns start to pop out of
her head and she starts to take on this
more demonic form the really cool thing
about her teleportation powers that you
see in the trailer are that she's
actually opening portals to a separate
dimension that they call limbo where she
is
sorceress supreme and has absolute power
just like dr. strange is sorcerer
supreme in the main Marvel Universe in
the comics she can also teleport through
time but I don't know if they're going to
make her that powerful in this first
movie the director actually just
confirmed my big
theory about the sequel so originally
the movie was planned to be a trilogy
they were going to  have a big post-credit
scene with Antonio Banderas he was
actually going to play Roberto de Costa's
father who is part of the Hellfire Club
in the comics and he be the main villain
of the sequel in terms of mutants and
these characters inside the MCU they're
actually treating this movie the New
Mutants movie the same way the MCU is
going to treat Deadpool 3 the movie
Deadpool the character Ryan Reynolds
will be part of the MCU eventually but
Deadpool 3 is going to be rated R and
because Disney does not release rated R
movies and doesn't want that kind of
tone inside the MCU Deadpool 3 is going to
be treated like it exists in this own
little bubble of continuity you know it
could reference anything that it wants
make fun of any Marvel characters that
it wants but you're not going to see old
Chris Evans Captain America show up
during Deadpool 3 and you're not going
to see the other big Avengers characters
pop in later what'll happen though is
you'll have an MCU team-up movie like
Avengers 5 or some big crossover movie
Deadpool will appear during that but
he'll be written in a more pg-13 way
because all the MCU movies tend to be
pg-13 it's a whole different story for
the mainstream a rebooted x-men movies
like obviously Marvel is working on a
new x-men movie eventually it's not
going to happen for a long time but a
really good example of them introducing
mutants into the MCU is the new version
of Wolverine so what they're doing right
now is they're building on pre-existing
MCU continuity to introduce the new
x-men characters long-term the really
cool thing about the new version of
Wolverine is that they're going to surface
him through the Weapon X program so
think about it this way you go back to
the Incredible Hulk film look at what
Thunderbolt Ross is doing he's talking
to Emil Blonsky about the super soldier
program that he just brought out of the
mothballs when he goes in to grab some
new Super Soldier Serum the cannister
actually reads weapons plus the weapons
Plus program is what the Weapon X
program is part of its Weapon 10
Wolverine is Weapon 10 the 10th
iteration of the weapons Plus program
Captain America was designation weapon 1
in the weapons Plus program within the
Falcon and Winter Soldier series that's
going to be airing on Disney Plus later
this year they're also bringing back the
Super Soldier program the weapon
Plus program so they're just slowly
setting up the concept of Weapon X and
that's where the new Wolverine will
debut but everyone let me know in the
comments when do you think we're
actually going to see them transition
from weapons Plus and get to that Weapon
X how many movies do you think is going
to be we've got a big venom 2 trailer
that'll be coming really soon more
Morbius trailers more spider-man stuff
Tom Holland did reveal that they're
still going to start filming spider-man
3 this summer
so a lot of stuff that's happening later
this year still seems like it's going to be
ok so don't worry too much about that
right now
everyone click here for that new Marvel
Falcon in Winter Soldier teaser trailer
video and click here for that brand new
Black Widow trailer with all the new
taskmaster footage thank you so much for
watching everyone stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight!